What are you rebelling against?
What you got.
Canada's freedom convoy started
three weeks ago with truckers from
the east and west coasts of that
country converging on Ottawa to
protest a law requiring that
they be vaccinated to come back into
their own country, given that well
over 80 percent of the truckers are
vaccinated.
What exactly are they protesting?
As one reporter who talked to dozens
of demonstrators put it, it's less
about vaccine mandates and more
about a sense that things will never
go back to normal, a sense that
they're being ganged up on by the
government, the media, Big Tech,
Big Pharma truckers complained about
inflation and about being demonized
as dumb and irrational.
They feel underappreciated by elites
who tell them what to do without
giving them any say in their own
lives. One protester gave eloquent
voice to populist resentment, saying
"There's a group in power that
always manages to create panic
among the masses and siphon off
public funds." The trucker protests
remind me of the Tea Party in 2009,
Occupy Wall Street in 2011,
the Women's March in 2017
and Black Lives Matter protests
after the police killing of Michael
Brown in 2014 and George
Floyd in 2020.
Whatever specific event ignited
each of those movements, they
all quickly took on greater
proportions and expressed the vast,
generalized anger not
simply at overspending, bailouts,
income inequality, sexism and police
brutality, but governments
and cultural elites that seem at
best indifferent to ordinary
people's lives and at worst,
downright malevolent.
These movements typify what former
CIA analyst Martin Guthrie
wrote about in the Revolt of the
Public and the Crisis of Authority
in the New Millennium.
Governments and elites have lost the
trust and confidence of the people
they supposedly serve.
Social media and other forms of
communications empower protest
movements that are authentic,
decentralized and leaderless,
at least at the beginning.
They're much better at articulating
rage and anger at the status quo
than they are at proposing anything
like concrete proposals for reform.
That was certainly the case with the
Tea Party, which started out as a
revolt against wild spending and
bank bailouts during the financial
crisis. The movement brought
hundreds of thousands of protesters
to the streets all over the country.
It captured the libertarian
imagination with its simple message
of controlling government spending
and holding businesses and people
accountable for bad decisions
because capitalism is supposed to be
a system of profit and loss.
The Tea Party wave got a handful of
people elected to Congress in 2010
and 2012, including Senator
Rand Paul, who's cheering the
Canadian truckers on an even calling
for an American version of the
freedom convoy.
"Clog things up, make people think
about the mandates.".
But the Tea Party ultimately faded
into insignificance and impotence,
in large part because it could only
articulate frustration and
negativity.
It was quickly absorbed into a
Republican party that failed
at every step to reduce the size,
scope and spending of government.
The Canadian freedom convoy will
likely suffer a similar fate.
Some of the other recent protest
movements have been much more
successful in pushing an agenda,
but all have lost urgency
and effectiveness as they became
more centralized and enmeshed
with Partisan politics.
Their leaders, just like the heads
of the governments they're
protesting, abuse their
power and thus lose their moral
authority. But that doesn't mean new
protest movements don't matter.
Far from it.
Even if they don't succeed at
achieving their stated goals, their
blows against the status quo whose
cumulative force will make
governments and elites become more
accountable to the very people they
ultimately rely on.
As with the collapse of communism,
eventually there comes a tipping
point where the seemingly impossible
becomes the inevitable.
In a country where arbitrary COVID
policies still run rampant, trust
and confidence in government,
business and organized religion
continues to fall.
Inflation is at a 40 year high,
and just 17 percent
of us are satisfied with the way
things are going.
Expect many new movements to rise
up soon. As a society,
we're like Marlon Brando in "The
Wild One." We may not know the best
way forward, exactly.
But that's not going to stop us from
pushing into the future.